ce que je vous propose dans un premier
temps c'est de passer en revue les
aphrodisiaques les plus fréquemment
cités et de voir ce dont l'efficacité a
été prouvé scientifiquement allez c'est
parti le gingembre le ginseng le ginko
le Gino non pardon je tenter un truc le
piment les épices le bois bandé les
huîtres les fraises le miel les avocats
les graines de courge la figue noire les
asperges le Tribulus la Maca la Macarena
Reina bah oui la vérité c'est que aucune
étude scientifique n'a jamais démontré
qu'aucun de ces aliments n'était
véritablement aphrodisiaque d'ailleurs
aphrodisiaque c'est même pas une notion
scientifique c'est plutôt une notion
marketing un truc pour faire vendre donc
quand vous lisez ça